un non lieu ou la cour d'assises pour
omar raddad on sera fixée prochainement
au marais ce jardinier de mougins qui
est accusé du meurtre de ghislaine
marchal
la veuve de l'empereur des accessoires
automobiles l'instruction est terminée
le dossier sera examiné cet après midi
par la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel d'aix-en-provence
mais ce n'est que dans deux semaines au
mieux qu'on connaîtra la décision la
justice dominique verdeilhan gagnait
lefebre de dos entouré de trois
gendarmes
omar raddad c'était en février 92 huit
mois après les faits lors d'une
reconstitution dans le pavillon de
ghislaine marshall une riche héritier
retrouvée morte barricadés dans la
chaufferie de sa ville à la chamade
elle a succombé à une longue agonie
après avoir été blessés de neuf coups de
poignard seul indice un témoignage
posthume de la victime écrit avec son
propre sang omar m'a tuer tuer er drôle
de fautes pour une adepte des mots
croisés et c'est ici après deux ans
d'enquêté le seul élément à charge
contre le jardinier car l'examen de son
emploi du temps le jour du meurtre
n'apporte aucune certitude au mardi
avoir quitté son travail chez madame
pascale à 12h puis s'être arrêté dans
une boulangerie du val de mougins
seulement personne ici ne s'en souvient
à 12h15 omar est arrivé chez lui au
cannet dans le hall de l'immeuble au
mardi avoir vu le gérant d'un
supermarché voisin
une présence que confirme ce dernier à
12h45 aux mains repart vers mougins et
s'arrête à 12h51 pour appeler ses
beaux-parents conversation confirmée par
france télécom omar reprendra son
travail à 13h05 pour l'accusation
omar n'a pas d'alibi pour la défense ce
timing serré ne lui permettait pas de
commettre le crime
autre point de discordance le mobile
c'était un flambeur
disent les uns ce n'était pas son
intérêt disent les eaux tuer quelqu'un
qui le faisait vivre un peu aussi
puisqu'il avait séjourné pour ça
résultat les magistrats d'aix se
retrouvent cet après midi devant une
énigme et fasse un réquisitoire
accablant la défense pointe le doigt
vers un dossier plein de faiblesse
toujours à nice est une formidable
bataille d'experts autour d'une faute
d'orthographe qui va dominer à partir de
demain le procès d'omar raddad le
jardinier marocain de 31 ans accusé du
meurtre d'une riche héritière ghislaine
marchal rappel des faits avec dominique
verdeilhan 24 juin 91 une villa sur les
hauteurs de mouches à la propriété a
pour nom la chamade
inspiré d'un livre de françoise sagan
mais ici s'arrête le romanesque pour
laisser place au polar dans la cave et
retrouver madame marchal vol héritière
des lampes à la tête de chat elle est
morte exergue son agonie aurait duré
entre 15 et 30 minutes sur les murs une
inscription
omar m'a tuer o'hare omar c'est le nom
du jardinier marocain on l'arrête sans
résistance de sa part il nie la voisine
de la victime qui faisait également
appel aux jardiniers prend la défense de
ce dernier
c'est un grand travailleur et un garçon
un être gentil doux et surtout
travailleurs qu il est pour sa petite
famille et voit la reconstitution
audition expertise n'apporte aucun
élément probant
l'inscription posthume reste le seul
élément consistant de l'accusation
pour le juge le mobile serait l'argent
la faute d'orthographe n'est pas un
problème l'accusé en revanche n'a pas
d'alibi
côté défense on se fixera qu'un seul
objectif démontrer que madame marchal a
écrit la phrase accusatrice en présence
de son assassin ce qui exclut la
possibilité qu'omar soit le coupable
avril 93 le père d'omar attend un non
lieu
ce seront les assises janvier 94 divorce
du côté de la défense
incompatibilité d'humeur maître vergès
reste seul avocat pour une défense de
rupture
côté parties civiles en revanche on
affiche la prudence
on est dit dans ce dossier beaucoup de
choses fausses bonnes choses erronées
la presse a fantasmé meriem un débat
public et contradictoire dans ce débat
la victime fait entendre sa parole c'est
ça que je veux faire
omar raddad a dix jours pour faire
oublier son nom d'une inscription écrit
en lettres de sang l'homme qui se
présente ce matin devant ses juges offre
deux images d'abord celle d'un l'accusé
souriant détendu confiant
celle enfin d'un homme impatient lorsqu
il attend quelques minutes dans un
couloir que le président armand jay en
donne l'ordre de le faire comparaître
dans le box un patient de clamer son
innocence publiquement car depuis les
faits en juin 91
omar raddad ni mais depuis deux ans et
demi la justice ne veut pas l'entendre
pour elle le crime est signé de la main
même de la victime omar m'a tuer
face à lui la soeur de ghislaine marchal
est le fils de la victime tous deux
assisté de m henri leclerc attendent de
ce procès
confirmation de leurs soupçons omar
toujours souriant quand il aperçoit au
fond de la salle
son père quant à la défense elle a subi
une rupture il ya trois jours les
divergences dans l'attitude à adopter
ont poussé les deux avocats présents
depuis le début a quitté le dossier
seuls restent donc maître vergès maîtres
pétillot ce matin assistant l'accusé un
interprète un interprète dont la défense
dénonce amèrement l'absence aux côtés de
leurs clients lors des premiers
interrogatoires
chose rare lors de l'ouverture d'un
procès devant une cour d'assises
l'absence ce matin des pièces à
conviction
cela souligne bien la difficulté de
cette affaire car l'arme du crime par
exemple n'a pas été retrouvé les
éléments matériels sont minces si ce
n'est inexistant aux douze jurés donc de
la cour d'assises des alpes maritimes de
dire dans une dizaine de jours
quelle lecture ils font de cette
inscription en lettres de sang omar
raddad est il la sacem de ghislaine
marchal toujours pas de réponse à la
cour d'assises des alpes maritimes pour
tenter de l'obtenir magistrats et jurés
veulent déceler le mobile et mieux
connaître la victime dominique
verdeilhan et gilles dobler sont à nice
de la sphère de l'accusé christian
veilleux ne veut pas
et il se limitera donc à évoquer par
quelques mots la victime
nous avions 19 ans d'écart plus qu'une
mère ce fut une amie une confidente
ma mère dit il avait un profond respect
pour les autres sa mort fut un drame
épouvantable et cela continuera sans
doute mais je pense que n'importe super
dans une mer s'est déjà affirmé dans ces
conditions là je crois qu ce effroyable
pour ses amis la riche héritière des
landes marshall n'était pas la mondaine
évaporé qu'on a voulu dépeindre
ghislaine marchal était une femme de
caractère juste mais exigeante avec ses
employés solitaire discrète secrète à la
chamade sa villa sa vie était calme et
ranger il aurait fallu des sévices très
grave pour la faire écrire ce qu'elle ne
voulait pas avance un de ses amis madame
marchal cinglante et agacé selon sa
femme de ménage lorsque omar venaient
lui demander une pelle fois une avance
des familiers de madame marchal qui
évoque aussi sa passion des mots croisés
ou il reconnaît un témoin avait cherché
l'orthographe exacte dans les
dictionnaires
oui écrire tu es er elle en était
capable
je vous le promets non quand on a god is
on ne fait pas la dictée de bernard
pivot
rien de déterminant donc mais c'est là
au moins le mérite de faire rentrer le
procès dans une enquête qui elle non
plus ne manque pas de faute
j'avais de la justice la suite du procès
d'omar raddad à nice à la journée était
consacrée aux circonstances de la mort
de ghislaine marchal
dominique verdeilhan a suivi cette
audience ce matin et en début d'après
midi
compte rendu trois pièces à conviction
pour tenter de résoudre une énigme un
lit pliant un chevron de voix une barre
métallique point commun les trois objets
sont maculés de sang celui de la victime
ce sont là pour les jurés les seuls
éléments matériels et visible de ce
dossier
à eux de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
le 23 juin 91 dans la cave
le lendemain lorsque les gendarmes
tentent de pénétrer dans le sous sol de
la ville là il constate deux choses
primo la porte est fermée à clé à double
tour secundo l'ouverture se fait
difficilement à l'audience face aux
jurés
un des gendarmes reconstitue le
mécanisme qui bloquaient la porte
le lit et la barre métallique en
position de levier pour empêcher
l'ouverture pour la défense d'omar ce
dispositif accrédite la thèse de la
machination
mais le gendarme est catégorique pour
lui il est impossible de monter un tel
mécanisme
en sortant de la cave autrement dit la
personne qui a écrit omar m'a tuer et
qui s'est barricadé et la mène
les 12 jurés comprennent donc
aujourd'hui la difficulté de leur tâche
avant d'être 12 juges
on leur demande de se transformer en
sherlock holmes autre procès autre
affaire très mystérieuse c'est le procès
d'un marshall à dadis est il oui ou non
l'assassin de ghislaine marchal c'est ce
que la justice tente de comprendre et de
savoir au quatrième jour d'audiences on
a examiné l'emploi du temps d'omar
raddad le jour de l'assassinât de madame
marchal dominique verdeilhan compte
rendu omar raddad a perdu son sourire du
premier jour sans doute perçoit-il que
les débats ne tourne pas à son avantage
omar à la recherche d'un alibi le
dimanche 23 juin 91
omar raddad jardine dans la propriété de
madame pascale une voisine de madame
marchal le jardinier déclare être rentré
chez lui en mobylette à 5 km de là pour
déjeuner dans une boulangerie de bal du
moulin ils déclarent avoir acheté du
pain à la barre les deux employés disent
n'avoir aucun souvenir de son passage
ensuite l'homme dit être arrivé chez lui
avoir entraperçu
un voisin dans le hall de la résidence
pourtant aucun des locataires se
souvient avoir vu un homard ou son
vélomoteur
en revanche les témoins confirment bien
avoir été là au moment dit madame
pascale ami de la victime mais farouche
partisane de l'innocence d'omar d'y
avoir reçu le soir même de la découverte
du corps alors que les circonstances du
crime n'était pas connue un appel
téléphonique
une voix anonyme lui aurait dit il en
fait de belles votre jardiniers avec
tout ce sens c'est assurément trop blanc
mais alors pourquoi avoir attendu six
mois pour en parler aux gendarmes
on attendait de ce procès qu'il est
lucide une énigme
en fait il ne fait que renforcer un
mystère au détriment d'omar raddad cinq
jours d'audience est toujours la même
énigme est toujours la même question
omar raddad est il l'assassin de
ghislaine marchal question d'autant plus
difficile que mystère s'ajoute à tous
les autres les experts ont du mal à
déterminer l'heure du crime dominique
verdeilhan hervé poggio sol maître
leclerc maîtres du granrut beau frère de
la victime était présent ce matin sur le
banc de la partie civile
le fils et la soeur de madame marchal
ont préféré ne pas entendre les détails
concernant une agonie en sous sol une
quinzaine de plaies un peignoir de bain
maculé de sang un descriptif macabre est
une préoccupation générale
l'heure du crime trois médecins légistes
ont tenté de définir un créneau horaire
pour s'arrêter six mois après les faits
au dimanche 23 juin vers 13 heures
mais à l'audience la défense sort de sa
poche son expert un médecin ni soins qui
met en doute les conclusions de ses
confrères le diagnostic d'un témoin
passe à la science de trois experts et
maître vergès de plaider hors audience
l'erreur judiciaire
celui qui fait les premières
constatations dit je fais confiance au
dessus il n'a pas à faire confiance au
dessus
il a à dire si à cette heure là elles
étaient vivantes ou man et l'autre
arrive qu'ils n'étaient pas là pour la
levée du corps est dit moi je fais je
lui fais confiance à lui et ça mène à
ceux ci c'est un pur scandale
ils furent crois qu'il est temps de
dénoncer ce scandale nous pouvons dire
aujourd'hui que nous ne savons pas quand
il est bon ben voilà et ce procès
devient donc une nouvelle fois le top 6
d'une enquête bâclée
pour les jurés le dernier espoir d'y
voir clair ce sont les experts
graphologues ils seront entendus lundi
ainsi la cour d'assises se retrouvera au
point de départ de la faire autrement
dit l'inscription posthume alors omar
haddad saura si outre son nom c'était sa
condamnation qui était inscrite à nice
journée capitale au procès d'omar raddad
où l'on a présenté aux jurés le seul
élément à charge contre l'accusée
mais un élément de poids puisqu'il
s'agit des deux portes de la villa de
mougins portant l'inscription en lettres
de sang omar m'a tuer compte rendu
d'audience dominique verdeilhan hervé
pozzo il y a ceux qui voudraient bien
voir voir cette fameuse inscription en
lettres de sang dont on parle depuis
joint 91
et puis il ya ceux pour qui ces dix
lettres ne sont pas une preuve mais
seulement la main d'une machination
la cour d'assisses touche enfin du doigt
le mystère de mougins lehning devient
réel l expert en graphologie va conduire
les jurés dans ce huis clos macabre tel
qu'il analyse première porte celle de la
cave à vin le scripteur est à genoux
l'inscription est lisible
omar m'a tuer 1er 2e porte celle de la
chaufferie sim est 50 plus loin la
victime est allongée à bout de forces
elle ne peut plus continuer son message
et ne peut pas finir d'écrire le mot tué
entre les deux portes les signes d'une
agonie comparaisons à l'appui pour
l'expert c'est évident l'écriture est
spontanée et non guidés maître vergès se
transforme en top 1 en robe noire lui
aussi s'est basé sur des mots croisés de
la victime mais il n'arrive pas au même
résultat mais les graphologues persiste
et signe
madame marchal est l'auteur elle était
suffisamment lucide pour savoir ce
qu'elle écrivait mais ce qui surprend le
plus une fois encore c'est l'attitude de
marc haddad dans cette salle d'audience
devenue salle de classe il reste absent
comme un bon élève qui veut se faire
oublier
face aux deux portent sur lesquels
figurent son nom il reste imperturbable
en quoi suis-je concernés lance-t-il
même aux présidentes géant omar m'a tuer
dix lettres pour résoudre une énigme dix
lettres pour juger un homme dit l'être
aussi pour donner de l'accusé une
définition en ville être innocent ou
coupable c'est demain komara date sera
fixée sur son sort aujourd'hui devant la
cour d'assises des alpes-maritimes
l'avocat général a requis une peine de
17 à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle pour
je cite un crime par excellence crime de
lâcheté d'indifférence et d'horreur
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan hervé pozzo
dans part de traces de larmes pas de
trace de l'argent deux constats que l'on
retrouvera sûrement demain dans la
plaidoirie de maître vergès
car avant de convaincre les jurés
l'avocat plaide l'innocence de son
client dans la salle des pas perdus
quelques instants auparavant l'avocat
général avait requis entre 17 et 20 ans
de réclusion criminelle
pour bernard farret dix éléments
convergents font une preuve
ghislaine marchal dit il n'a pas pu se
tromper de bonne foi le meurtrier a agi
de passe elle l'a donc parfaitement
identifiés tout nous ramène à omar
constate le magistrat
ce n'est pas un crime de rôdeur car il y
a eu ni vol ni fouille ni effraction
pour maître leclerc nous ne sommes plus
dans le mystère le roman et la fiction
nous sommes dans la douleur et l'infini
souffrance
omar m'a tuer c'est un ultime message à
la famille et à vous les juges il ne
faut pas nier ce message demande
l'avocat maître leclerc qui souligne
qu'il n'a pas besoin des experts pour se
forger une conviction absolue il y a
aucune contestation possible toute autre
hypothèse est absurde mais plus fort
encore que les mots des plaidoiries et
du réquisitoire il y a ceux de la
victime le président armand djian avait
pris soin de laisser devant les 12 jurés
les deux portes et leur inscription
comme si au delà de cette ultime message
courageux de madame marchal
on voulait y voir aussi ses dernières
volontés
la condamnation à 18 ans de prison
d'omar raddad provoque pas mal
d'interrogations dans le monde
judiciaire de nombreux magistrats et
avocats s'émeuvent de ce verdict en
souhaitant à l'avenir une possibilité
d'appel devant une autre juridiction
pour position déjà rejetée par le garde
des sceaux pierre méhaignerie enquête
dominique verdeilhan lorsque le père
d'omar raddad sort de la salle
d'audience mercredi il est abasourdi il
attendait l'acquittement la
reconnaissance de l'innocence que son
fils avait proclamé le matin même dans
le box d'autres espérait simplement que
le doute comme c'est le principe profite
à l'accusé
ce soir 18 avocat affirme qu'omar raddad
a été condamné à 18 ans de prison sans
charges suffisantes
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya
véritablement lieu de s'interroger sur
l'absence de motivation dans les
décisions de la cour d'assises et sur
l'absence de la possibilité de faire
appel lorsqu'on sait qu'une petite
condamnation devant le tribunal
correctionnel on peut aller devant une
cour d'appel
si vous êtes condamné comme ce garçon à
18 ans de réclusion criminelle vous ne
pouvez pas faire appel de la décision
une réforme de la cour d'assises exclu
par la chancellerie
le procès d'omar raddad est une nouvelle
affaire dreyfus estimé mercredi métro
vergès un parallèle qui n'est guère du
goût des magistrats niçois ce matin le
président armand djian lors de
l'ouverture d'un autre procès a fait
part publiquement de son indignation
considérant avec le procureur de nice
que maître vergès avait gravement
repenser les magistrats et les jurés
populaires il était donc tout à fait
inadmissible et intolérable de leur
prêter le crime le plus grave qui est
celui du racisme et donc de s'être
déterminé uniquement sur la couleur de
la fusée se basant sur un article de loi
réprimant qu'il compte encore à jeter le
discrédit sur un acte de justice
le procureur demande donc que l'avocat
soit poursuivi mais le dernier espoir de
marc haddad réside dans une décision de
la cour de cassation où c'est le droit
qui est étudiée et non les faits la loi
est stricte à l'interdît de commenter
une décision de justice pourtant huit
jours après la condamnation d'omar
raddad pour le meurtre de ghislaine
marchal les critiques abondent celle
d'avocat
le magistrat d'intellectuels mais aussi
et c'est beaucoup plus rare
jurés qui ont eu à juger le jardinier
marocain dominique verdeilhan innocent
innocent ce sont les seuls mots comme un
raddad a prononcé en français durant son
procès c'était le matin même du verdict
des mots que les jurés en grande
majorité n'ont pas voulu entendre pas
plus qu'ils n'ont été convaincus par la
défense tardive de maître vergès
parmi les neuf jurés populaires
quelques-uns d'entre eux se sont confiés
à un journaliste de vsd
ils confient leur trouble ressenti tout
au long des sept heures de délibéré
soulignant comment selon eux la religion
du doute pu écarter un doute qui en
principe doit profiter à l'accusé
des confessions anonyme de jurer que la
loi interdit au nom du secret des
délibérés mais des confessions qui
illustrent au sein même de la cour
d'assises le malaise suscité par ce
verdict malaise ressenti aussi par des
intellectuels des artistes à l'appel du
journal globe 40 personnalités demandent
la tenue d'un autre procès mais
aujourd'hui seule la cour de cassation
peut en décider
solitude du juré en salle de
délibérations
certains d'entre eux se sont déclarés
favorables à une possibilité d'appel en
cour d'assises
revendiquant ainsi publiquement leur
droit à l'erreur maître henri leclerc
bon cela dit j'avais plaidé comme je
disais tout à l'heure dans le procès
d'omar raddad au nom de la victime que
pensez-vous du moto défense de m moi je
n'apprécie vie je n'ai pas à donner
d'appréciation sur le mode de défense de
m vergès moi je fais part de ce qu'était
ma conviction et de ce qui est toujours
là comme conviction dans cette affaire
le problème le problème ce que je crois
pas que la justice
ce show de son discrédit et en main en
faisant des poursuites contre contre des
propos qui sont les propos de l'homme
qui a subi un échec et qui est et qui
cherche à rejeter les causes de cet
échec ailleurs si la justice est
discréditée par cela c'est qu'il ya
d'autres problèmes de la justice et je
pense qu'elle ferait beaucoup mieux de
s'intéresser à ces problèmes de fond que
l'on envisageait des poursuites est ce
que vous êtes pour une réforme des
assises hachures je suis pour une
réforme des assises
je suis pour une réforme des assises
depuis très longtemps et je n'ai
absolument pas changé de position sur ce
sujet je pense que notre système
d'assise est très important qu'il ne
faut pas toucher au jury est une
institution de
public mais je pense qu'il faut modifier
les assises il faut modifier d'ailleurs
l'ensemble de la procédure qu'elle soit
plus sûr qu'elle soit meilleure et si
l'on change les assises il faut en
particulier bien entendu prévoir un
appel en cours et si c'est évident autre
question d'actualité quelle est votre
position en tant que vice-président de
la ligue des droits de l'homme sur les
visas de sortie pour les ressortissants
de 13 pays où bon je crois que c'est une
des conséquences tragiques une des
conséquences logiques j'ai dû la loi d'
de ces lois de la loi du 24 août 93 de
monsieur pasqua contre laquelle on vous
manifestez 20000 personnes ya peu de
temps les sports oms on dénonce les gens
d'un certain nombre de pays que l'on
sélectionne qui sont soit on les montre
du doigt qui sont suspects qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs des ressortissants de ces
pays ou même des apatrides et réfugiés
de ces pays il suffit d'abord et
originaires de ces régions pour être
suspect il ya là quelque chose qui est
gênant pour la france sur le plan
diplomatique et qui est préoccupant
seulement des libertés
revenons maintenant à votre ouvrage un
combat pour la justice et une
autobiographie de 40 ans pas seulement
de celle d'un avocat pénaliste mais
aussi d'un militant politique du parti
communiste au ps si vous avez défendu
des militants gauchistes des membres du
fln des arméniens des antilles et avant
de venir l'avocat de la cfdt
retenez vous la conviction qu'un avocat
doit être engagé politiquement
non je pense qu'il peut y avoir des
engagements politiques pour évoquer
qu'il peut y avoir des avocats engagés
politiquement ça a été mon cas c'est mon
cas c'est à dire que je suis engagé dans
un certain nombre de combats mais je
pense aussi qu'il y ait des avocats
qu'ils peuvent ne pas l'être
ceci étant je crois qu'il faut toujours
être engagées dans le combat que l'on
mène pour sa thèse pour cette cause
quand on est avocat on ne peut pas être
un avocat désengager c'est pas possible
alors c'était un livre effectivement
parle énormément bien sûr de vous même
et donc des procès des grands procès il
ya sur pour lesquelles vous avez été
avocat et c'est un livre qui est paru
donc à la découverte témoins et c'est un
livre d'entretiens
avec nord que largo pourquoi parce que
c'était ni d'entretien vous savez le
principe des livres d'entretiens c'est
d'abord que écrire un livre c'est très
très lourd très long très difficile
livre d'entretiens donne au moins un
cadre c'est à dire que celui qui
interroge fixe un cadre et est lui-même
intéressé par un certain nombre de
choses et puis dans ce cadre on répond
on peut donc faire les choses plus
rapidement
omar raddad est en prison il a été
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion pour le
meurtre de ghislaine marchal
mais son avocat jacques vergès tient à
tout prix à l'innocenter et il pense
être sur la bonne voie avec un
témoignage inattendue d'une voisine de
la victime dominique verdeilhan jan
cornet le 25 avril dernier patricia
clark néo zélandaise déclarant résider à
mougins écrit à m vergès elle vient de
lire son livre
omar m'a tuer le dimanche 23 juin 91 à
15h30 devant son portail à trois
kilomètres et demi de la villa de madame
marchal
elle dit avoir vu une camionnette sans
plaque d'immatriculation à l'intérieur
des taches de sang des chevrons de voir
le vendredi la camionnette a
mystérieusement disparu reste un sac
plastique contenant des papiers tâches
et de brun est un tournant j'ai
téléphoné à la gendamerie et je décris
là
sacs en plastique et ils ont dit non non
ne faisons pas ça c'est trop long je
pense qu'ils ont dit que c'était trop
long buts b les gt1 témoignage que
n'aurait donc pas retenu les gendarmes
qui enquêtaient alors sur omar le
jardinier marocain pour maître vergès
il doit permettre d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire et prouve selon
lui la partialité des enquêteurs quand
madame cloud il ya une camionnette ça
n'intéresse pas messieurs les gendarmes
se sont intéressés par un vélomoteur
quand elle dit li a tournevis ils
répondent c'est trop petit
nous ce qui nous intéresse est un coupé
c'est des gens qui quarante huit heures
après
alors y at il eu un véhicule devant chez
madame clark ce soir à mougins la police
municipale et la fourrière démentent
avoir enlevé une camionnette à cette
date là côté gendarmerie aucun
commentaires apparemment certaines
investigations ont été menées dès cet
après midi
mais là encore c'est à la justice
d'élucider le mystère de la cabinet
fantôme
madame monsieur bonsoir omar raddad
jardinier marocain condamné en février à
18 ans de prison pour l'assassinât de
ghislaine marchal n'était semble-t-il
pas le seul
omar connu de la victime l'hypothèse de
l'existence d'un autre homme prénommé
omar originaire de l'ex-yougoslavie et
recherchées semble-t-il par des
détectives privés est en tout cas
confirmés par les avocats de la défense
mais apparemment elle n'avait pas été
prise au sérieux par les enquêteurs
enquêtent valérie ermite domine
verdeilhan pour monsieur raddad
son fils est innocent aussi l'existence
d'un autre homme marc dans l'entourage
de ghislaine marchal n'est en soi pas
une surprise
ça vous fait quoi quand on dit qu'un
autre marc peut-être c'est cela c'est le
tarmac pour vous et pour vous c'est pas
votre fille fait pas le mot marne
c'est de la première journée d'essais
omar m'a tuer dix lettres qui ont amené
les enquêteurs sur la piste du jardinier
marocain qui travaillait entre autres
chez madame marchal une accusations
posthumes coupable était tout désigné
seulement
selon libération il existe un autre
marque la police serait la recherche
d'une relation de la victime originaire
d'ex-yougoslavie et qui aurait quitté la
france après le meurtre une piste que ne
démentent pas aujourd'hui les avocats
d'omar raddad qui reste néanmoins très
prudent si un lien était établi entre la
victime et ce second tome art il est
évident qu'il y aurait matière à
remettre en cause les données d'une
procédure
mais pour l'heure il les hâtifs de tirer
toute conclusion il ne faut pas
sacrifier à la gesticulation
il faut demeurer dans le sérieux ainsi
le mystère marshall s'épaissit de jour
en jour seule certitude c'est bien omar
haddad qui a été condamné à 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle
nada
condamné en février à 18 ans de prison
at il payé pour un autre après la
révélation hier par le quotidien
libération de l'existence d'un second
omar qui aurait été très lié à ghislaine
marchal la famille de l'homonyme d'omar
raddad en tout cas nie tout contact avec
la victime de ce crime
le point de cette enquête compliquée
avec valérie ermite le 2 février dernier
omar raddad est condamné à 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour le meurtre de
ghislaine marchal condamné à être celui
que désigner ces lettres de sang écrites
sur la porte de la chaufferie l'affairé
close mais les interrogations vont
demeurer les interrogations les rumeurs
et puis cette confidence qui parvient
aux oreilles de m go do quelques temps
après le procès j'ai reçu une lettre
d'un confrère m'indiquant qu'une de ses
clientes dignes de foi savais qu'il y
avait un deuxième mort dans l'entourage
de madame marchal très naturellement
nous avons demandé à ce que cette
information soit vérifiée dans le cadre
d'une enquête privée l'existence d'un
autre marée vite confirmée par un
détective l'existence certes mais rien
pour le moment ne permet d'établir avec
certitude un lien direct entre ce jeune
homme de 24 ans et madame marchal un
lien que dément formellement le frère de
cet autre marque que nous avons joint au
téléphone hier pour diffamation
mais cheyrou quelqu'un vous appelle en
disant vous n'êtes rien meurtre appel
entendu difficile en l'état d'aller plus
loin
d'autant qu'aucun service de police ou
de gendarmerie n'ait saisi de la faire
mais ce nouveau rebondissement démontre
une fois encore le goût d'inachevé
coralie sic et cette enquête et ce
procès aujourd'hui dans le journal
nice-matin suite de la sphère ghislaine
marchal depuis qu'un enquêteur privé a
découvert qu'il pouvait exister jean
provient conditionnelle qu'il pouvait
exister un second personnage prénommé
homard dans l'entourage de la veuve
assassiné le doute
c'est donc insinué pour autant ce matin
donc ce jeune homme prénommé au marais
qui habitent la région de mougins dément
formellement dans ce journal avoir connu
de près ou de loin la victime le point
valérie est remis didier beaumont près
de trois ans après le meurtre de
ghislaine marchal la villa de la chamade
garderait t-elle encore des secrets
c'est en tout cas la conviction intime
de bernard n'arrange ou depuis un an et
demi ce détective privé travaillent dans
l'ombre sur la terre marchal il y
environ deux mois
il trouve la piste d'un autre marc dont
il semble convaincu qu'il faisait partie
de près ou de loin de l'entourage de la
victime sans en tirer d'autres
conclusions il communique cette
information à mettre boudou l'un des
premiers avocats d'omar raddad
je trouve que la diffusion de
l'information est tout à fait prématuré
dans la mesure où nous souhaitions
savoir qu'elle était l'intimité des
relations pouvant avoir existé entre ce
second omar et madame marchal non pas
pour en tirer une conclusion quelconque
qui est un coupable de remplacement de
substitution mais simplement pour
mesurer l'importance de cette
information dans la perspective d'un
recours en révision
omar numéro 2 subitement à la une de
tous les journaux mais il dément
formellement et dit ne pas commettre
ghislaine marchal et il m'a dit
formellement gimp le décès par alain
marschall c'est un garçon qui tient à 24
ans qui est étudiant qui n'a pas
difficile parce que ses parents tiennent
situation aisée au contraire de mardi
qui paraît-il je n'en sais rien à des
fins de mois difficiles
je vous dis ah y'a rien de sérieux là
dedans simplement que ce garçon depuis
48 heures depuis trois jours est
assailli par les journalistes et lci à
des gens d'être journaliste devant la
maison son prénom jeté en pâture et la
famille de cette autre marc n'entend pas
s'arrêter là
l'avocat compte assigner en justice le
seul quotidien qui a cité son nom
d'autant qu'aucun service de police
n'étaient en mesure actuellement
d'enquêter sur cette nouvelle piste tant
que la cour de cassation ne s'est pas
prononcé omar raddad reste donc en
prison je vous le disais la cour de
cassation vient à l'instant de rejeter
le pourvoi formé par ce jardinier
marocain condamné à 18 ans de prison
pour le meurtre de sa patronne la
décision vient donc d'être rendus sur
place dominique verdeilhan au fil de la
lecture de l'arrêt maître jacques vergès
comprend omar raddad vient de perdre un
nouveau combat avec la justice il ne
sera pas rejugé après trois heures de
débat près de trois heures de délibéré
les magistrats de la cour de cassation
vienne purement et simplement de
confirmer le verdict de nice omar raddad
est donc définitivement condamné les
magistrats n'ont pas suivi les avocats
d'omar raddad pour ces derniers leurs
clients n'avaient pas été jugés dans les
règles de l'art
l'arrêt de la cour d'assises était
entachée suspecte parce que
dactylographié pré-rédigés et faisant de
omar raddad à un condamné d'avancé tu es
là pour la défense la manifestation
prohibé de l'opinion du président de la
cour d'assises des alpes-maritimes ma
réaction est d'une très grande déception
déception non seulement pour omar raddad
qui est innocent des crimes pour
lesquels il a été condamné
mais déception pour la justice aussi
parce que dans les attendus que j'ai
entendu je pense qu'il y à un recul des
droits de la der du respect des droits
de la défense
la cassation tant attendu par omar
raddad mais aussi par une partie de
l'opinion publique n'a donc pas lieu et
c'est la deuxième fois qu omar haddad ne
bénéficient pas
à nice il s'agissait d'un doute quant à
sa culpabilité
a paris il s'agissait d'un doute quant à
l'équité de son procès les avocats
maintenant d'omar raddad savent qu'ils
n'ont plus qu'un seul recours une
révision de son procès mais les avocats
le savent la justice n'aime pas dire
qu'elle s'est trompée
peut-être un nouveau rebondissement dans
l'affairé omar raddad son jardinier
marocain qui purge actuellement une
peine de 18 ans de prison pour avoir tué
sa patronne lemarchal
selon le témoignage d'un ancien détenu
de clairvaux récemment libéré un autre
détenu aurait confié qu'il était
l'auteur du crime enquête maryse burgot
dominique verdeilhan je connais le
véritable assassin de madame marchal
telle est l'affirmation faite à un
journal marocain par un ex-détenu selon
cet homme un certain f b âgé de 32 ans
cambrioleurs notoire lui aurait avoué le
crime de mougins le mobile
le vol est une vengeance d'ordre privé
cette confidence aurait eu lieu à la
prison de clairvaux dans l'aube
en 94 ce mystérieux témoin souhaite
garder l'anonymat
mais ce soir la direction de la prison
nous a confirmé son passage à clairvaux
en 94
joint par téléphone à rabat l'homme
renouvelle ses révélations que s'est il
passé
il vous a dit que c'était lui qui avait
assassiné madame marchal depuis le
procès d'omar raddad en janvier 94 c'est
le troisième rebondissements ce fut
d'abord le témoignage tardif de madame
clark faisant état d'une camionnette
suspecte le jour du crime puis ce fut la
piste d'un second omar dans l'entourage
de la victime
de quoi rendre prudents l'avocat de
marada il y à cette information qui
vient du maroc il ya d'autres
informations qui me sont parvenues aussi
en dehors du témoignage de madame
plaques dont je pense toujours qu'il est
un témoignage sérieux
d'autres informations sur lesquels je
travaille
rebondissement plus médiatique que
judiciaire car pour la justice omar
raddad demeure l'assassin de madame
marchal madame monsieur bonsoir omar
raddad condamné à 18 ans de prison pour
le meurtre donne à marshall va-t-il voir
son procès révisée en tout cas le
parquet de grasse a reçu des
instructions pour lancer une enquête
préliminaire afin de vérifier le
témoignage d'un ancien détenu qui
innocenterait le jardinier marocain
maryse burgot et christian hottin ont
rencontré au maroc
l'homme qui pourrait faire basculer à
nouveau le destin d'omar raddad
c'est dans la médina de meknès au maroc
que nous avons rencontré ce témoin qui
intéresse aujourd'hui la justice
française il est de nationalité
marocaine et c'est à cause de son
témoignage tardif qu'une nouvelle
enquête préliminaire a été ouverte ce
soir par le parquet de grasse dans la
sphère omar haddad
ce marocain affirme en effet aujourd'hui
comme un raddad ne peut pas être
l'assassin de ghislaine marchal
le véritable assassin il dit le
connaître celui ci lui aurait avoué son
crime en prison alors qu'à la télé on ne
parlait que de cette affaire est née des
écoutes ne m'en parle plus de cette
affaire je vous parle plus de cette
affaire le lendemain à me rencontrer et
me raconterez tout comment ça se passe
et que c'était nuit il n'est pas allé
pour la tuer sur quoi la comberie parce
que hélas verrait sa femme madame
marchand parce que madame marchal avait
viré sa faim voilà il voulait se venger
et il est arrivé pour la cambrioler que
c'était pareil comme elle a trouvé là
dedans et ne savait pas qu'elle était
ils sont ainsi trouvés entre dans la
même chambre et c'est là que la tuer
avec les avec le couteau de madame
marchand lui il avait pas d'armes
n'avaient rien
une confidence que notre témoin aurait
donc reçu ici au centre de détention de
clairvaux il y purgeait lui même une
peine de prison
et il a attendu sa libération pour
parler j'ai gardé mon secret gd le jour
quand je suis libre de clairvaux que
j'ai me tombe ma liberté je faire
classer cette affaire dans mon pays
pourquoi dans votre pays et parce que
dans mon pays je suis en sécurité
un témoignage dont la justice française
cherche aujourd'hui à vérifier la
crédibilité
c'est en effet la troisième fois depuis
la condamnation d'omar raddad que l'afer
est relancé
mais les deux pistes précédentes
s'étaient révélées peu crédible nous
passons maintenant à une affaire qui a
déjà fait beaucoup parler la sphère du
jardinier omar raddad qui avait été
souvenez-vous condamné pour le meurtre
de sa patronne alain villas-boas accusé
par un autre détenu d'être le véritable
meurtrier a été entendu aujourd'hui par
les gendarmes de grâce il nie les faits
et il a été laissé en liberté par les
gendarmes qui l'ont tu entendu nouveau
rebondissement dans la sphère omar
raddad le jardinier condamné pour le
meurtre de son employeur madame marchal
une controverse s'engage entre un
détective privé qui affirme avoir
retrouvé l'armé du crime et d'autre part
l'une des employées de madame marchal
qui avoue avoir fait un faux témoignage
alban nicosie diebolt la découverte d'un
couteau sur cette plage de cannes dans
les rochers risque de relancer une fois
de plus la sphère marshall d'après la
description que m'a fait une
une personne de la chamade ce couteau
ressemblerait étrangement un couteau qui
a disparu que dans 1 janvier 92 en
faisant mes mentors s'est aperçu qu'il
manquait
bernard naranjo et détective privé voilà
trois ans maintenant qu'il tente de
prouver qu omar le jardinier est
innocent un ouvrier notamment lui dit
avoir entendu une voix de femme dans la
villa après la mort de madame marchal et
puis il y à ce couteau retrouvé donc ici
une semaine après le meurtre par pablo
le compagnon d'une employée de maison
le détective a porté il ya quelques
jours ce couteau à la gendarmerie de
grasse un ustensile non rouyer qui
intrigue tout particulièrement les
enquêteurs
c'est un endroit ou pas vous avez
l'habitude de venir avec des amis ainsi
que mots d'amour retrouve olivier
liliane receveaux était à l'époque
employée de maison chez madame marchal
le 23 juin 80 ans elle dit à son
compagnon qu'elle va travailler à la
chamade problème c'est faux j'étais le
23 mai transmis au dac cela concerne
croix avec ma fille nadège eric le husky
comment j'avais dit à pablo ce travail
ce jour là parce qu'il est trop ami
j'avais envie d'avoir des week ends les
enquêteurs se rendront en principe
demain chez madame receveaux pour
l'entendre sur ses activités exactes le
jour du meurtre
liliane receveaux souhaite à l'occasion
porter plainte en diffamation contre le
détective privé la sphère marshall n'a
décidément pas fini de faire parler
d'elle
24 heures
mesure de grâce partielle accordée par
le prion la république à omar raddad
jardinier marocain condamné à 18 ans de
prison pour le meurtre de sa patronne
ghislaine marchal la décision continue
de provoquer des réactions et d'après
l'avocat du jeune homme maître vergès
qui lui a rendu visite aujourd'hui à la
prison de grasse et bien la libération
d'omar raddad pourrait bien avoir lieu
avant deux ans comme cela a été dit hier
yasmina farber philip man il est 15h 10
quand jacques vergès arrive à la maison
d'arrêt de graaf
ce sera la première visite rendue à omar
raddad depuis l'annnonce d'une grâce de
quatre ans et huit mois accordé au
jardinier marocain
l'avocat avait déposé un recours en
grâce il ya quelques semaines son client
et bien sûr soulagé d'autant que sa
libération pourrait intervenir plus vite
que prévu on a dit que omar haddad
devrait attendre deux ans je ne sais
quel expert juriste a soufflé cela aux
journalistes mais cet expert juriste a
oublié une seule chose c'est les remises
de peine
quant à prisonniers fait cinq ans de
prison
en fait ça lui compte pour 6 ans et 3
mois mais en fonction de sa chose qu'on
peut dire déjà ce que le délai connais
pas graphics hernan aimé en moi à
mougins sur les lieux du crime de
ghislaine marchal certains revit
blanquette
comme ce voisin de la veuve est
assassinée les gendarmes ne l'ont
entendu que deux mois après le drame il
travaillait à 450 mètres de la maison et
qu'il était donc obligé de passer devant
chez nous et bien messieurs les
gendarmes
mon pneu en considération l'enquète et
le procès ont laissé un sentiment
d'inachevé dans l'opinion publique
la mesure de grâce partielle ne lève pas
totalement le voile
maintenant s'il n'est pas qu'on pourrait
réviser complètement rien et recomptent
tous les témoins bascule est quelque
chose d'inacceptable
omar n'est pas innocenté mais pour ses
défenseurs cette mesure de clémence
reste un premier pas pour nous
l'essentiel c'est qu'ils soient libres
rapidement mis un santé aussi bien mais
ceci n'empêche pas les efforts qu'on
fera pour qu'il soit réhabilité m'aider
mais au moins qu'ils attendent le
résultat de ces efforts dehors et non
pas dedans être libre pour un nouveau
combat
la demande de révision de son procès
c'est demain comme harada doit sortir de
prison après avoir purgé sept ans de
réclusion criminelle pour un meurtre
qu'il a toujours nié celui de son
employeur madame marchal sa libération
rendu possible par une grâce
présidentielle partielle était en fait
conditionnée à l'obtention d'un emploi
fixe une entreprise marseillaise tenus
par des marocains se propose de
l'employé désormais la nique à roucy et
gérard gallien un couloir de plus
celui-ci ne débouche pas sur une cellule
de prison mais dans un atelier de
manutention le futur univers
professionnel d'omar raddad dont prince
et c'est vendre promesse d'embauché ce
qu'on apprenait ces néo là on s'est
engagé envers omar haddad et son
entourage c'est fort un travail de
manutentionnaire corse et dans ce
secteur là donc les expéditions des
command transformation de viande donald
charcuterie produits laitiers c'est
l'une des sociétés leaders dans le
domaine
le groupe compte 160 salariés et pour
les autres employés
la venue d'auch marque ne va rien
changer
malgré sa notoriété sa publicité qu'il a
pu avoir malgré lui quoi c'est la même
chose pour nous ce soir omar haddad ou à
la grâce à la promesse d'emploi de cette
entreprise omar serait donc l'idée après
deux refus la chancellerie vient
d'accepter cette nouvelle proposition
le directeur marocain de la société
contactée par des proches d'omar avait
quant à lui donné son accord
immédiatement on en penser ils ont un
peu de difficulté de trouver une
entreprise où il peut s'intégrer
facilement et souhaita quelques roger
apparemment et nous on a pensé que
c'était l'entreprise idéale pour lui et
c'est ça peut l'aider
on a dit pourquoi pas on l'a plutôt
tendez la main la société ben wood
emploi un tiers de marocains accueillir
omar est pour elle une autre façon de d1
compatriote omar haddad l'un des
prisonniers les plus célèbres de france
a retrouvé ce matin la liberté après
avoir purgé sept des 18 années de
réclusion criminelle auxquels il avait
été condamné pour le meurtre de
ghislaine marchal
devant la centrale de muret en
haute-garonne christophe la rocca
olivier combe et gilbert usa
8h10 ce matin un large sourire
omar raddad vient de franchir le guichet
de la centrale de muret il embrasse son
avocat jacques vergès
après sept ans de détention omar raddad
grâce à cette libération conditionnelle
retrouve le monde extérieur et la foule
des journalistes
c'est très con étage sous les doigts
aujourd'hui mais je ne suis pas très
content avec et qui me l'a déjà kg je
soulèverai mme le combat continue
jusqu'au bout comment se sont passées
ces sept ans j'ai très mal passé c'est
aussi un détaillant les baruya jeu
quelque chose là et je suis très fatigué
je vois dit remercier et à tout le monde
à tous les jeunes soutiennent et merci
pour le chocolat est resté à l'écart un
homme observe la scène
c'est un voisin de ghislaine marchal
persuadé de l'innocence d'omar
il est venu spécialement de mougins pour
participer à l'émotion est toujours se
trouver maintenant je vais pas être
rappelé à sa vie est foutue
mais pour maître vergès l'émotion ne
doit pas masquer le fond l'avocat
demande la révision du procès d'omar
raddad
il a sa liberté aujourd'hui matin il
s'agit de lui restituer son honneur
et quand je pense que quand je dis
restitue son honneur au marada sait
restituer son honneur la justice
française aussi parce que condamner un
innocent parce qu'il est étranger parce
qu'il est il est prêt parce qu'il ne
peut pas se défendre pour couvrir
quelqu'un de nantir de protéger
c'est une autre maître vergès ne
clarifiera pas à ces accusations
dix minutes après la libération d'omar
raddad il prendra la route en compagnie
du jardinier direction les bouches du
rhône dans l'affairé omar raddad la
justice française vient d'ordonner de
nouvelles expertises graphologiques pour
essayer de lever le mystère sur la
fameuse inscription
omar m'a tuer alors ces mots ont-ils
réellement été écrit par la victime
ghislaine marchal la justice veut ton
être sur valérie ermite fanni au vernis
innocence ces mots prononcés juste avant
sa condamnation à 18 ans de réclusion
criminelle
omar raddad n'a jamais cessé de les
répéter partiellement gracié après plus
de sept ans de détention
le jardinier marocain a recouvré sa
liberté il y a dix sept mois mais son
combat ne s'est pas arrêté pour autant
je le comprends ça fait peur
il y a un an son avocat a déposé une
requête en révision de son procès parmi
les éléments soulevés la comparaison
entre les lettres de sang désignent ans
omar comme coupables et l'écriture de
madame marchal la victime jean paul
gaultier est expert en écriture il a lui
aussi effectué cette comparaison et ses
conclusions diffèrent de celles des
experts du procès
je n'ai pas trouvé de lettres types et
c'est à dire de similitudes sur des
formes type et qui permettent de dire
que c'est
marshall qui a écrit et ses lettres de
chant c'est hyper maître vergès
la commission de révision vient
d'ordonner de nouvelles expertises
graphologiques j'ai produit une
quinzaine d' expertise faite par des
experts près des cours et tribunaux qui
tous affirment cette écriture n'est pas
de madame marchal
c'est peut-être un premier pas sur le
chemin de la révision du procès mais un
premier pas seulement car en dix ans sur
503 verdicts d'assises
la commission n'a saisi que trois fois
la cour de révision des nouveaux doutes
dans la sphère omar raddad condamné en
1994 pour le meurtre de sa patronne puis
graciée selon de nouvelles expertises
graphologiques rien ne prouve que la
fameuse inscription omar m'a tuer a
vraiment été écrit par ghislaine marchal
sur le mur avant de mourir valérie
ermite
c'était l'une des pièces maîtresse de
l'accusation
omar m'a tuer des lettres de sang
désignent le coupable en 1994
omar haddad est condamné à 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle
à l'époque les graphologues affirmé que
son auteur était bien la victime
elle-même des conclusions toujours
contestée par l'avocat du jardinier
une nouvelle expertise ordonnée par la
commission de révision conclu
aujourd'hui que l'on ne peut pas
affirmer que c'est la victime qui a
écrit cette phrase maintenant audi
cette inscription peut pas dire que
c'est madame marchal qui l'a fait alors
sa chose tout est renversée si ce n'est
pas madame marchal qui a écrit c'est
quelqu'un d'autre et ce n'est pas est ce
quelqu'un d'autre est un familier qui
accusent omar parce qu'il connaît
l'existence du jardinier donc ça ne
devient plus une accusation ça devient
une manipulation partiellement gracié
omar raddad est en liberté
conditionnelle depuis deux ans mais le
jardinier marocain qui a toujours clamé
son innocence voudrait être entièrement
réhabilité par la justice
la commission de révision qui instruit à
nouveau la sphère attend de nouvelles
expertises pour décider si oui ou non
omar haddad doit être rejugé un jour la
sphère omar raddad connaît à nouveau
développement fut une expertise du
laboratoire de police conclut que de
l'adn masculin
les ou sang de la victime ghislaine
marchal le jardinier marocain qui a été
condamné puis gracié après sept ans de
détention
demande que son adn soit comparé à celui
retrouvé sur les lieux du crime
les explications de claire perdrix ellis
galant et georges une angoisse ces
traces de sang vont-elles enfin parler
il y a le célèbre omar m'a tuer
il y à aussi l'empreinte d'une main
ensanglantée des traces retrouvées dans
la villa où ghislaine marchal a été
assassiné en juin 91
on sait qu'il s'agit du sang de la
victime mais les experts viennent de
déceler dans les empreintes de l'adn
masculin peut être du sang peut être
aussi de la peau de la sueur
cette expertise scientifique a été
réclamée par maître vergès l'avocat
d'omar raddad
selon lui l'assassin aurait tracer ces
inscriptions avec le sang de la victime
pour faire accuser son client omar
raddad qui a toujours clamé son
innocence a accepté de se soumettre à
des tests génétiques comparatifs et
c'est lui l'assassin il doit pas faire
cette inscription qui le dénoncent mais
pour plus de sûreté
omar raddad est tout à fait d'accord
pour qu'on compare son adn à cet adn
trouvées dans la trace semble lente et
j'espère que cela se fera avant la fin
de l'hiver dans les deux mois qui
viennent
accusé par ses lettres de sang le
jardinier omar raddad avait été condamné
en 94 à 18 ans de réclusion criminelle
pour le meurtre de sa patronne
gracié quatre ans plus tard par jacques
chirac ils obtenaient une liberté
conditionnelle depuis son avocat n'a
cessé de réclamer de nouvelles
expertises et la révision du procès ou
quoi l'instruction n'a rien fait pour
trouver la vérité
on s'est contenté d'un soupçon d'un
préjugé et on n'a pas essayé d'avoir le
coeur net
en laissant des traces d'adn sur les
lieux l'assassin a certainement signer
son crime
les résultats des tests génétiques marco
rue peuvent être les pilotes de cette
saga judiciaire hors du commun
omar raddad condamné pour le meurtre de
ghislaine marchal commis en juin 91 à
mougins dans les alpes maritimes
pourraient peut-être bénéficier des
éléments d'une nouvelle expertise
scientifique confirmant que l'adn
masculin
mêlés au sang de la victime pour écrire
omar m'a tuer n'est pas celui de marne
commentaire parce qu'elle dit c'est bon
omar m'a tuer ces quelques mots écrit
avec le sang de ghislaine marchal
viennent de livrer un de leurs derniers
secrets
les scientifiques de la police avait
détecté un adn masculin mélangées au
sang de la victime
trois tests ont été effectués deux
d'entre eux indiquent que les traces d
adn n'appartiennent pas à omar raddad
les résultats du troisième test ne sont
pas encore connus la police scientifique
parisienne remettra ses conclusions à la
justice en début de semaine prochaine
alors de qui proviennent ces fameuses
traces de salive ou de sueur mélangées
au sang de la victime
les experts n'ont pas la réponse pas
plus qu'ils ne savent à quel moment
elles ont été déposées sur la porte
avant ou pendant le meurtre après lors
des multiples manipulations personne ne
le sait pour l'instant
alors ce soir une seule chose est sûre
l'analyse n'accuse pas omar raddad
elle ne le disculpe pas pour autant
l'homme a été condamné à 18 ans de
prison par la cour d'assises de nice en
94 avant d'être partiellement gracié par
le président de la république
il a toujours clamé son innocence depuis
ses avocats se battent pour l'ouverture
d'un procès en révision
les résultats des analyses
constitue-t-il un élément nouveau pour
la cour de cassation
rien n'est moins sûr les magistrats
devraient prendre leur décision au
printemps
en février 94 omar raddad avait été
constatée condamné à 18 ans de prison à
l'époque la cour d'assises c'était en
grande partie appuyés sur l'inscription
omar m'a tuer tracé en lettres de sang
sur une porte de la chaufferie
les résultats d'analysé d'hier confirme
que l' enquête a été menée d'une manière
approximative et que les gendarmes ont
accumulé les négligences
dix ans après l'assassinât de ghislaine
marchal la vérité n'a toujours pas
éclaté olivier sainte marie stéphane
sauter les enquêteurs se sont surtout
focalisés sur cette fort et les
inscriptions qu'elle comportait omar
haddad a immédiatement été arrêtés et le
corps de madame marchal incinérés une
procédure rapide mais jugée normale par
l'un des avocats de la famille de la
victime ghislaine marchal
ayant elle-même désigner le coupable a
priori il apparaissait tout à fait
évident que dans la mesure où elle avait
elle-même accusé omar raddad de l'avoir
tué il n'y avait pas grand doute sur la
culpabilité de celui ci par conséquent
qu'on ait permis son incinération dans
les jours qui ont suivi il n'avait rien
de spécialement anormal
rien d'anormal sauf que cette
incinération empêche tout contre
expertise sur le corps de la victime
s'est elle battu avec son meurtrier
avait-elle sous les ondées petit bout de
peau de sang de son assassin il est
aujourd'hui trop tard pour enquêter dans
cette direction maître vergès en tant
que défenseur omar raddad a engagé un
détective privé
ce dernier s'est employé à déterminer
les zones d'ombré de l'enquète une
pellicule photo avaient été retrouvés
dans la villa de madame marchal
elle sera détruite par les enquêteurs
après une erreur de manipulation dans
l'appareil photographique de madame
marchal il devait y aura des
photographies de proches à ma la marche
et si ces photos étaient versés au
dossier
et bien évidemment cela pouvait
impliquer une éventuelle participation
de ces personnes et on a préféré les
écarter de manière à ce qu'on ne puisse
même pas l'évoquer autre zone d'ombré la
date et l'heure exacte de la mort de
madame marchal dimanche 23 juin lundi 24
juin 91 aucune certitude du côté des
enquêteurs de la gendarmerie lors du
procès on s'était beaucoup pas tardé sur
l'analyse graphologique du fameux omar
m'a tuer à l'époque formel les
graphologues doute aujourd'hui que les
mots accusateurs et pu être écrit par la
victime
enfin de nombreux témoins n'aurait
jamais été auditionné par la gendarmerie
une nouvelle enquête a été menée par la
commission de révision mais ces
résultats ne sont toujours pas connues
les résultats du test adn communiqués
hier ne prouve pas l'innocence d'omar
raddad mais c'est un pas de plus un
élément supplémentaire et qui pourrait
me permettre la révision du procès c'est
en tout cas ce que pensent les avocats
du jardinier marocain la famille de
ghislaine marchal elle parle d'un coup
de bluff repartage dominique dumas
laurenceau omar haddad veut sa
réhabilitation d'ici deux à trois mois
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré ce matin dans
le journal la provence
des traces adn retrouvées sur la porte
où avait été écrit omar m'a tuer avec le
sang de la victime ghislaine marchal ne
sont pas les traces d'omar raddad pour
la défense et adn inconnue est un espoir
de révision
ce parti est le moment où on trouve pas
son adn sur la porte
ça prouve et ce que dit la défense qui
n'était pas là au moment des faits ça
vous laisse entrevoir
bon espoir d'obtenir en face procès en
révision je crois que s'il n'y a pas de
procès en révision avec cet élément là
il n'y aura plus jamais de procès en
révision en france pour la partie civile
ces trois adn inconnue n'apporte rien de
nouveau à lenquête le fait qu'on ait
retrouvé une tâche de l'adn sur la porte
d'une chaufferie ne signifie rien
d'ailleurs dire que cette tâche est mêlé
au sang de madame rêve marshall séparé
en plus inexacte
ce qui aurait été étonnant c'est qu'il
n'y ait traces d'adn de personnes sur
une porte de chaufferie qui a été
fréquenté par des ouvriers des gens qui
ont manipulé cette porte en diverses
occasions
je dirais même que y aurait-il une trace
d'adn et n2 marada humaine que ça
n'aurait pas non plus été l'épreuve
décisive car il aurait pu toucher cette
porte en d'autres circonstances
des résultats plus complets devraient
être remis prochainement la cour de
cassation une révision d'une procédure
rare dont la décision appartient aux
seuls magistrats au chapitre judiciaire
ces deux mcs sera examinée la demande de
révision de la condamnation d'omar
raddad le jardinier marocain
actuellement en liberté conditionnelle
mais son objectif est de bénéficier d'un
nouveau procès qui l'innocenterait du
meurtre de ghislaine marchal
pendant plus d'un an la commission de
révision a mené sa propre enquête de
maele en débattra valérie arbitres le
geste de la victoire de la liberté et du
nom combat d'omar raddad alors même qu
omar était encore en prison les avocats
préparer sa requête en révision
pour ce faire un détective privé a mené
l'enquêté pendant trois ans il dit avoir
relevé plusieurs contradictions dans les
déclarations où les emplois du temps de
proches de la victime et notamment dans
celui de l'ex femme de ménage
j'ai recueilli les témoignages j'ai
ouvert ses interrogations à eux d'y
répondre
chacun son rôle destinataires de ces
investigations la commission de révision
mais il semble qu'elle ait préféré une
autre voie pour enquêter beaucoup plus
scientifique cell la première de ces
interrogations qui a écrit en lettres de
sang omar m'a tuer des graphologues ont
à nouveau comparé l'inscription
accusatrice à l'écriture de madame
marchal
leur conclusion est simple il est
impossible de dire qui est l'auteur de
cette phrase
deuxième interrogation l'heure de la
mort de ghislaine marchal
les nouveaux légiste ne la situe plus
dimanche entre 11h45 et 14 heures mais
entre 8h du matin et 20 heures le soir
enfin en analysant les portes
les experts ont trouvé mêlé à une trace
de sang de la victime
un adn d'hommes ce n'est pas celui
d'omar raddad
on ne sait pas qui a écrit omar m'a tuer
on ne sait pas à quelle heure précise
madame marchal est morte et on ne sait
pas qui appartient cet adn d'hommes qui
n'est pas celui d'omar et qu'on retrouve
dans le sens de madame marchal
ces trois faits nouveaux qui à mes yeux
justifie en bois devant une nouvelle
cour d'assises pour la partie civile ces
éléments ne disculpe en rien omar raddad
l'adn masculin aurait pu être déposées
avant ou après le meurtre lors des
diverses manipulations des portes comme
d autres pièces à conviction d'ailleurs
sans compter pour la partie civile
les autres éléments du dossier le fait
que ces inscriptions ont été faites avec
son sens qu'elle était bloquée par elles
mêmes dans la carte que personne n'a pu
s'en sortir et que personne ne savait
comme harada travailler ce jour-là s'est
élevé à subsistent pour qu'omar raddad
bénéficier un jour d'un nouveau procès
la commission de révision devra d'abord
dire si ces nouveaux éléments sont de
nature à faire naître un doute sur sa
culpabilité
l' affaire omar raddad la commission de
révision de la cour de cassation va se
prononcer sur une éventuelle annulation
de la condamnation de celui qui avait
été reconnu coupable en 1994 du meurtre
de ghislaine marchal à mougins dans les
alpes-maritimes le rappel des faits
maintenant avec valérie ermite
c'est la première image de ma raddad
en juin 1991 la france découvre le
visage du tueur présumé de ghislaine
marre
le 24 juin dans ce quartier huppé de
mougins le corps de la victime est
découvert dans sa cave avant de mourir
madame marchal se serait barricadé avec
une barre de fer et un lit pliant
mais surtout elle aurait par deux fois
désigné pensent tant son assassin omar
omar matures les graphologues de
l'époque sont d'ailleurs formel c'est la
victime qui a écrit cette phrase saisie
par la défense
la commission de révision a ordonné une
série de contre expertise des
graphologues ont à nouveau comparé les
lettres de sang à l'écriture de madame
marchal
leur conclusion est simple il est
impossible de dire qui est l'auteur de
cette phrase
deuxièmement le créneau horaire possible
de la mort de la victime et selon les
nouveaux experts beaucoup plus large que
pour les premiers légiste mais surtout
l'adn va parler dans cette trace de main
de madame marchal annabi and home sera
extrait et il n'appartient pas à omar
raddad
ces trois faits nouveaux qui à mes yeux
justifie en bois devant une nouvelle
cour d'assises
autant dans le dossier de l'instruction
tout était ficelé en fonction de
l'emploi du temps d'omar raddad autant
maintenant nous sommes dans la city d2
plus complète
la partie civile ne partage évidemment
pas la même analyse pour l'avocat l'adn
masculin a pu être déposé avant ou après
le meurtre lors des nombreux maniement
des portes sans compter les autres
charge du dossier
le fait que ces inscriptions de
technique avec son centre qu'elle était
bloquée par elle même dans la cas que
personne n'a pu s'en sortir et que
personne ne savait comme harada
travailler ce jour là c'est et moulins
subsistent
dix ans après les faits omar raddad lui
dis toujours croire que la justice le
réhabilitera un jour en reconnaissant
son innocence l' affaire omar raddad son
jardinier marocain accusé d'avoir tué sa
patronne ghislaine marchal en 91 connaît
un nouveau rebondissement plus de dix
ans après le meurtre un étrange témoin
vient en effet de faire des révélations
pour le moins troublantes selon lui la
riche héritière aurait été assassinée
par des adeptes de l'ordre du temple
solaire
les explications de pascal justice ce
nouveau témoin s'appelle dit moir
il s'est manifesté spontanément auprès
du procureur de grasse le 28 décembre
dernier soit plus de dix ans après le
crime de ghislaine marchal
il affirme que la riche héritière
retrouvée assassinée au pied de la
célèbre inscription omar m'a tuer aurait
été exécuté par des adeptes de l'ordre
du temple solaire selon lui ghislaine
marchal appartenait depuis 1982 à
l'hôtesse cette secte connu pour les
massacres et les suicides collectifs de
94 et 97
ghislaine marchal aurait été assassiné
parce qu'elle ne voulait plus financer
la secte et qu'elle souhaitait la
quitter guy warin prétend avoir été le
chauffeur du gourou joseph di mambro
aujourd'hui décédé il aurait conduit
trois membres de la secte le 24 juin 91
jour du meurtre devant le domicile de
ghislaine marchal
ce nouveau rebondissement intéresse bien
sûr l'ancien avocat de marc raddad le
jardinier condamné pour ce meurtre
il rappelle l'existence dans le dossier
d'un véhicule immatriculé en suisse
aux abords de la propriété de la victime
donc dossier un témoignage rapporté la
présence d'un véhicule automobile
immatriculée en suisse au portail de la
chamade dans une période contemporaine
de la mort de madame marchal
son meurtre dès lors il convient
effectivement que cette piste comme
toutes les autres soient fouillés parce
que décidée non aujourd'hui encore cette
affaire semble garder son mystère
les déclarations de guy warin sont
aujourd'hui en cours de vérification
même si enquêteurs et magistrats restent
sceptiques on se demande toujours
pourquoi il a attendu dix ans pour
témoigner et les membres de la secte
qu'il met en cause sont décédés
de plus ce témoin ne cache pas ses
démêlés avec la justice pour diverses
escroqueries
omar raddad le jardinier a toujours
clamé son innocence
mais il a été condamné pour ce meurtre à
18 ans de réclusion criminelle
libéré en 98 après sept ans de prison il
attend une éventuelle révision de son
procès car le meurtre de ghislaine
marchal comporte encore de nombreuses
zones d'ombré omar m'a tuer cette phrase
avait plus sûrement qu'une preuve
matérielle condamné à 18 ans de prison
mara date pour le meurtre de son
employeur
ghislaine marchal le président de la
république ayant partiellement gracié
par la suite omar raddad celui ci veut
aujourd'hui obtenir révision de son
procès il affirme être innocent et
certains aspects de l'enquète monteront
au moins que toute l'instruction a été
menée à charge contre le jardinier
marocain
pour autant l'avocat général chargé du
dossier est hostile à cette demande de
révision dominique verdeilhan eric mais
si le visage est grave
omar haddad sait que la partie n'est pas
gagnée c'est aujourd'hui que tout se
joue où tout se perd soit la révision
soit la fermeture définitive d'un
dossier vieux de 11 ans hier à son
arrivée à paris l'ex jardinier marocain
se montrait encore confiant omar raddad
croit en un second procès j'ai demandé
au saint coran troisième procès parce
que jarael
j'ai rien à voir dans cette affaire je
suis vraiment innocent et g
je souhaiterais s'offrir avec la justice
c'est la partie civile ce manque est
forte parce que ça fait des années et
son 22e sur le comptoir deuxième procès
et moi je comprends pas pourquoi ça me
contre un deuxième procès parce que à
mon avis et son port de la vérité mais
moi c'est au contraire je propose de
l'affairé tg cherche la vérité
pour maître vergès les certitudes du
procès en 94 ont laissé la place à des
hypothèses pour la défense la réponse
est dans les inscriptions sur les deux
portes en 94 elle avait condamné omar
haddad ou huit ans plus tard elles
peuvent l'innocenté métro vergès
s'appuie sur des expertises
graphologiques d'abord madame marchal
est elle bien l'auteur de ces lettres de
sang génétique
ensuite un adn masculin a été relevés
sur la porte ce n'est pas celui du
condamné
des arguments que maître georges kiejman
pour la partie civile ne trouve guère
convaincant la culpabilité de raddad est
dans le dossier dit il
la cour d'assises de nice ne s'est pas
trompé une position ferme sans faille
qui est également celle de laurent
davenas ce l'avocat général écartent
l'hypothèse d'éléments nouveaux
il requiert le rejet de la demande de
marc adam à l'avocat général qui ne
mâche pas ses mots pour définir le
travail de la défense il évoque je cite
une enquête mercenaires approximative
contre marc dit il il n'y a pas
d'élément nouveau
pas de doute il n'ya que des charges la
cour de révision devrait se donner
quelques semaines de réflexion
suis prêt à mourir pour la vérité omar
raddad réclame donc la révision de son
procès je vous rappelle qu'il avait été
condamné à 18 ans de prison pour le
meurtre de ghislaine marchal c'était en
91 puis gracié par le président de la
république il y a quatre ans la cour de
cassation examiné sa requête aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt mal parti puisque le
parquet s'y oppose dominique verdeilhan
eric mézil
je suis prêt à mourir pour la vérité
durant 15 minutes marada s'adresse aux
juges de la cour de révision le
condamner plaide lui même sa cause
je demande mille fois un second procès
c'est moi poursuit-il qui prend le
risque d'être rejugé après tout ça je
crains donc tous ces emprunts cyr et
pour moi et pour toute la france parce
que j'ai passé là bon côté français
réclame un deuxième procès je pense pour
les français qui sont en droit de se
voir la vérité c'est tout vous avez juré
plusieurs fois
j'ai joué parce que jamais parce les
maths demandé et c'est pour ça j'ai joué
parce que je suis sur certains de moi
c'est pas moi oui madame marchal et vous
dites qu'il vous a tué aussi
oui parce que partie civile ait dit et
ces quelques élèves qui s'offraient mais
des fois oui il est fort le résultat est
là il étudie matin marchand il me
ramenait raté à présent pour 18 raddad
innocent ce n'est pas l'intimé
conviction de laurent davenas
pour l'avocat général il n'y a pas
d'élément nouveau il n'y a pas de doute
il n'ya que des charges
il s'oppose à la révision au grand dam
de maître vergès je pense que les
déclarations de son avocat gerra sont
insignifiantes
il ya cette erreur fondamentale comment
peut-il dire que des traces d'adn dans
le sens de madame marchal ne signifie
rien
comment peut-il le soutenir qui a écrit
omar m'a tuer à qui appartient l'adn
masculin prélevés sur les portes puisque
ce n'est pas celui d'omar raddad
douze ans après les faits ce sont les
interrogations de la défense expertise à
l'appui des expertises qui pour
l'accusation et la partie civile ne
remettent pas en cause la culpabilité de
radanne je suis réconforté par le fait
que le ministère public partage mon
analyse du dossier
c'est à dire encore une fois celle des
faits et pas celle des déclarations
tapageuses ces dernières expertises sont
elles de la propagande mensongère comme
le pense laurent davenas cela
condamnation d'omar raddad et l
abracadabrante comme le soutient jacques
vergès la cour de révision donnera sa
réponse le 20 novembre